[Music]
And we are coming to you live from the
62nd session of the general conference
of of 7th Day Adventist here in St.
Louis, Missouri. This is I'd like to
know our Bible question and answer
program. My name is CA Murray and I'm in
the company of two distinguished men of
God. To my right, Pastor Daniel Miranda.
And to my left, Pastor Steven Boore, the
founder and president of this ministry.
I'd like to know is a wonderful program
that we love to do because it gives us
the opportunity to go into the word of
God to answer your questions, to as it
were, gentlemen, to scratch where the
the men of God, the women of God are
itching, and to answer their questions
and to see what's on their mind and on
their heart. We've got an interesting
program for you today and we want you to
stay tuned as we answer these questions.
Let me give you the contact point for
this particular minute. It is tv at sums
sum as in marytv.org.
That's TV at sumtv.org.
You want to get in on the fun, send the
questions. We'll give you the biblical
answers if an answer can be found. And
if we don't have an answer, we'll tell
you that too. Pastor Miranda, if you
would ask God's blessing uh on this
program, we'll begin with our first
question.
>> Absolutely. Let us pray. Heavenly
Father, which are in heaven, we thank
you so much for the opportunity of being
here from St. Louis uh doing this
program for your people. And I pray that
as we delve into these questions that
you may give us the understanding, the
discernment, the wisdom, and also the
ability to answer them in a way that may
be clear and applicable to everyone's
lives. We pray all these things in
Jesus' name. Amen.
>> Amen. We thought we would take
particular advantage of this setting to
have our questions come to us in person.
And so a number of people came and stood
before the camera and asked questions in
person. Our first one is from uh a young
man, we'll call him Mike. He's from
China. He's from the city of Hansu. He
came by. We actually, he told me, Pastor
Boore, have answered one of his
questions on air before. So he took the
opportunity to stand before our cameras
and ask his questions. So let's go to
that question just now.
>> Hello, my name is Yua. I'm from China
visiting GC session. Um I'm so grateful
that I can have a chance to ask a
question in uh secret unsale
um ministry. I do have a question
recently uh about the feeling um you
know in the Bible where I study um it
was uh encouraged that we we need to be
rejoice and in in the Lord always and
say it again uh rejoice it as in
Philippians 4:4
but uh um I found a lot of pressure in
life and in all the world, people
against people, nation against nation,
even uh external, internal, all the
pressure. So, um I also check the other
verse say lament and more and um weep uh
let your uh joy, let your laughter be uh
uh mourning and joy be groomed. in uh
James 4:9.
>> So how should I feel or how should I
even express my feeling? Um but I think
Jesus tells us that uh we need to be uh
blessed
uh if we more. So uh I would ask uh the
question how should we express our
feeling? Shall we just hide our feeling
just express the joyful expression or
just express anyway like uh short fuse
explosive? Um so that's that's my
question. Thank you.
>> Thank you Mike for this particular
question. Now he has actually sent us
this question also on email uh and
written it out for us. gentlemen, I
think what his his burden is, how what
should be our life's response to
troubles when we see them in the church?
What should be our response to the
gospel? It's it's a very nuanced
question and the answer is also uh a
very nuanced one. Should we be happy?
Should we be sad? Um I'm going to make a
statement, back it up with some text in
a minute, and then I'm going to uh let
you guys weigh in.
When we look at our own lives as far as
trouble is concerned, the Bible lets us
know that trouble is is uh or suffering
is part of our walk with Christ and that
we need to rejoice as we suffer. Uh he
mentioned uh Jeremiah. But when we look
at the sad state sometimes of God's
people,
>> then that's cause for for mourning. So
in one instance
if I'm suffering Ellen White says every
trial patiently born draws me closer to
Christ. But when I see the state of the
church sometimes then I should be sad.
We talk about Jeremiah. You look at
Jeremiah 15:1 God says you know if if
Moses and Samuel were to come before me
and intercede you're going to go into
captivity. Well that's something to be
sad about because it it's a commentary
on the state of God's people. But when I
personally have to suffer for Jesus, I
should rejoice because I'm suffering as
Christ suffered. Right? Who wants to
weigh in?
>> Well, I I can understand um the question
that Mike has because when you go to
Philippians, the verse that he was
quoting, it says, "Rejoice in the Lord
always." And it sounds like an absolute
always. But on the other hand, we have
verses like Ecclesiastes chapter 3 and
verse 4 that for example says a time
there is a time to weep and a time to
laugh, a time to mourn and a time to
dance. Now are these verses
contradictory? I don't think so. I think
Philippians is referring to a positive
attitude even under trying
circumstances. If you read Philippians
chapter 1, at the end, Paul is actually
warning the the the believers that
there's going to come a time of
persecution, a time of trial. And and
before that time, they should get ready
to have a positive mindset. Um, one of
the key words in the book of Philippians
is joy. Yes. Joy under trying
circumstances, joy under discouragement,
joy even in sickness, joy in health.
That doesn't that doesn't evade the fact
that human human beings have different
feelings. The expression of feelings is
not wrong. What is wrong is to distrust
God in trying circumstances. That is
wrong. But to to express especially for
example he was quoting about sorrow. Um
the Bible talks about the true sorrow
for sin. And and when I have fallen,
when I have grieved God and other
people, it is natural actually I would
be concerned if someone hurts God and
hurts others and doesn't feel anything.
It is natural to feel sorrow. But we
should not stay there. We should rejoice
because we have a savior that can
forgive us, that can heal us, that can
provide for our needs. So when we have
that positive mindset in that sense we
can always rejoice while experiencing
other feelings.
>> There's a couple of examples that I want
to uh share with you uh to answer this
question. It is possible to be going
through severe suffering and at the same
time be rejoicing.
>> Amen.
>> Uh you know we usually think of joy as
being synonymous with being happy.
They're two different Greek words.
The case of Paul and Silas,
they had their feet in the stocks. They
had been beaten 39 times on their backs.
And what were they doing in the prison?
>> Singing.
>> They were singing. They were rejoicing
before the Lord.
>> So it is possible to be rejoicing in the
midst of tremendous suffering.
>> Amen.
>> And then we have our greatest example,
Jesus Christ.
He cried out to his father, "My God, my
God, why have you forsaken me?" Clearly
going through severe agony. And yet in
the book of Hebrews 12:2, it says that
we are to look unto Jesus, the author
and finisher of our faith, who for the
joy that was set before him, endured the
cross, despised the shame, and has sat
down at the right hand of God.
>> Amen. So Jesus was suffering intense
agony, but at the same time he had
rejoicing and joy in his heart because
he saw all of the redeemed that we'd be
saved as a result of what he was doing.
>> So um we should not we should not
identify joy as being happy and
everything hunky dory. We should look at
joy as a divine uh gift that God gives
us to rejoice even in the midst of
suffering.
>> Well said. I I always say Jesus equals
joy. You know, I have a good Korean
friend who who who says, you know, you
cannot be happy all the time. You know,
if you go around smiling all the time,
people think you have a mental problem.
That's that that was his statement. But
you cannot be happy all the time, but
you can always have joy because even in
unhappy situations, you know, here's the
truth, gentlemen, and you know this.
Some days are not good days.
>> Yeah.
>> You wake up from the time your eyes
open, it's not going to be a good day.
You know, maybe you had something bad to
eat last night. Your stomach is
bothering you. You got some things on
your mind. It's not going to be a happy
day. But just because you're not happy
doesn't mean you lose the joy of Jesus.
So even on that unhappy day, through
that unhappy day, you can have joy in
your heart. Amen. So someone answer your
question, you can answer them patiently,
lovingly because of the joy. Not happy,
but you got joy.
>> Amen.
>> We praise the Lord. One quick reading,
then we'll go on to our next question.
Prayer, earnest, humble prayer offered
in faith amid the hours of darkness and
gloom brings light from heaven to the
soul. Peace comes to every heart for
every prayer offered in faith. So you
can have peace. The soul is lifted above
the clouds of darkness and error.
conflicts and passion, light, precious
light flashes from the throne of God and
is fitting up a feeble man to become
God's messengers in shedding light to
the world. Trials patiently born and and
this is found in many places in her
writings. Trials patiently borne,
blessings gratefully received,
temptations manfully resisted, meekness,
kindness and mercy and love exhibited
are the lights which shine forth in the
character before the world, revealing
the contrast with the darkness which
comes of selfishness and unrestained
passions of the heart into which the
light of life has never shown. So trials
patiently born, we all have them. uh dis
discouragements given to the Lord. Yes.
And as you well in tone to Daniel, God
doesn't mind questions. You know, the
prophets question him. Ellen White
questioned him. It's giving up on him
that he doesn't want. Exactly. Yeah. God
God is not too big for questions.
>> Yeah.
>> All righty. Uh thank you. Thank you so
very much, Mike, for coming by and
asking that particular question. Let's
go on to our next question uh which
comes from Allan. We don't have a
location but um thank you Allan for
sending in. Um I want to know what
Ezekiel chapter 4 means as the prophecy
and is it related to us that is the SDA
church. Um I want pastor Bora to help
with welldetailed information on it or a
video of the study. I'm a young man
growing in faith and I love to to share
uh I love to share truth and uh you
share you have made my spiritual life
grow more. So pastor Bore it's it's
addressed to you but of course we're all
going to chime in try to lift up your
hands you know as Aaron did Moses here
as you answer the question but do you
want to sort of jump out and and sort of
lead with with your answer?
>> Okay first of all we need to look at the
historical context of Ezekiel.
uh Jerusalem went through three
captivities
uh in the book of Ezekiel as well as
Jeremiah and Daniel. First of all, in
the year 605 BC,
uh Daniel and his friends and the
nobility were taken captive to Babylon.
The city didn't fall at that time. Then
in 597 BC, Ezekiel was taken captive to
Babylon. And then in the year 586 BC,
you have the destruction of Jerusalem by
King Nebuchadnezzar.
>> Yes.
>> So you have three stages in the
captivity of Israel uh spoken of in the
book of Daniel and in the book of
Ezekiel. Now with that in mind, we need
to understand that in uh here in Ezekiel
chapter 4 where it speaks about Jeremiah
lying on his side for an incredible
number of years. That is what we call an
acted parable.
It's it's kind of like in the book of
Revelation, you have uh God telling
John, "Eat the book." And when you eat
the book, it's going to be sweet in your
mouth and it's going to be bitter in
your stomach. Uh you know, he's acting
out a prophetic event that is going to
take place. And so when Jeremiah is told
there uh to lie in his or Ezekiel,
excuse me, is told to lie in his side
for a certain number of t years, that is
an acted parable that is teaching
something that is going to occur to
Israel. Um one final point is that this
is an oracle against Jerusalem,
God's professed people at that time.
We're not talking about uh this oracle
being directed at the uh you know the
pagan nations that were in the in that
area. We're talking about an oracle
against Jerusalem. And if you go to
chapter 8, you find that the greatest
sin that was being committed among those
who professed to be God's people was
that they were worshiping the sun.
Now I believe that this in principle not
in detail this prophecy of the specific
time period is not going to be fulfilled
again.
>> Um uh but in principle it's talking
about the apostasy of God's people at
that time. Just like in the Christian
world there's going to be an apostasy at
the end of time. And uh the greatest
apostasy in the in the times of Ezekiel
was that God's professed people will
worship the sun. at the end time it's
not going to be worshiping the sun
because we live in a sophisticated
world. It's actually going to be
worshiping on the day of the sun which
is the ba same basic principle because
uh you know worshiping the sun is
worshiping an object that god did not
create for worship and worshiping on the
first day of the week as a holy day is
not a day that God established as a day
of worship. So in principle it's the
same thing.
Yes, I was just going to u summarize
what pastor bore said. I I believe
Ezekiel like many other prophets
they wrote for their time. This is they
are called sometimes classical prophets
because their prophecies had a message
for their time but spiritually speaking
it also has some points and application
for the end times for us as well.
Whereas prophecies of Daniel and
Revelation, for example, they're called
apocalyptic prophecies. They're mostly
for the end of time. So, so yeah,
Ezekiel chapter 4 should be read as
Pastor Bore explained it within that
context of the siege of Jerusalem with
some spiritual elements that can also be
applied to the end of time.
I think uh and I agree with you both um
that this is is directly applicable to
Jerusalem. But when you go through the
Bible, since it is a unified book, you
can always find little things that point
to your time. That's correct. That you
can take information from. Uh and the
act prophecies, we've we've got them in
Ezekiel also. You know, the Lord tells
him, uh knock a hole in the wall and
don't go through the door, go through
the hole in the wall, uh kind of thing.
So, we see these over and over again.
This is God trying to, dare I say, shake
up his people to get them ready uh for
what is what is inevitably going to come
because they would not listen. Um it's
interesting that um in that last uh
destruction of Jerusalem, Zedekiah was
on the throne, you recall, and God told
him, if you just capitulate and kind of
behave yourself, you can get through
this. But he was hard-headed and he
ended up being drugged back to Babylon.
The city was was destroyed. Well,
>> if I could just add,
>> uh, the comforting news in this whole
scenario
>> is that God had a remnant that was
faithful in Jerusalem.
>> Yes. Amen.
>> Who, by the way, they were sealed on
their foreheads,
>> which is very There's a typology
involved here. Uh, you know, at the end
time, God's people have the seal of God.
They're spared from destruction, just
like, uh, those who were faithful in the
city were spared from destruction. So,
the book of Revelation picks up on the
prophecy of Ezekiel. Ezekiel and in
principle without talking about the
number of days that Jeremiah laid on on
his side and so on. Not Jeremiah,
Ezekiel laid on his side. Without the
specifics, in principle, it's fulfilled
again.
>> Amen. And amen. Good question and we are
thankful for it. Let's try to squeeze in
one more before our time slips away.
This is from Gracious and uh from the
country of Malawi. Here's the question.
After having the truth that Jesus was
shifting heavenly ministry from the holy
place to the holy of holies in 1844,
should we regard William Miller to have
had to have had given a lie unto his
hearers upon saying that it was to be
the time for the coming of Jesus? Would
you uh answer this according to quotes
in the Bible and the spirit of prophecy?
So she wants to know in in promoting
1844 and at the very end October 22 1844
was he was he promoting a lie?
>> I think we need to begin with a basic
principle and I would like to quote Acts
17 and verse 30. Acts 17:30 the Bible
says truly these times of ignorance God
overlooked but now commands all men
everywhere to repent. Now there is a
principle here that God overlooks the
times of ignorance. How do how do we
apply this to this particular case? We
need to understand that truth is
progressive.
Um the reformers didn't have all the
light.
>> True.
>> And yet we cannot accuse them of lying
because they were teaching error. That's
just they were doing the best they
could. In the same way with William
Miller, there were other things that he
didn't understand like the Sabbath truth
for example. Um actually, and you're
going to expand more on this. He was not
actually the one that came to 1844
first.
>> Correct.
>> Um so it wasn't that even he was he was
the one that first set the date. Um he
actually never put a specific date. He
gave approximations.
Yet at the end he adopted and he
believed it. But we cannot we cannot
blame William Miller for lying because
that's the bed that's the best he could
uh do. That was the best he could
understand in his time.
>> Furthermore, he was right about the
date.
>> The Millerites were right about the
date. It was the event.
>> They were wrong about the event.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> You know, and I think one way that we
can approach this is what happened at
the triumphal entry of Jesus.
You know when Jesus entered into
Jerusalem on that donkey and the
multitudes, the disciples were leading
the procession, you know, they thought
that he was going to enter Jerusalem. He
was going to take the throne. He was
going to establish his kingdom forever
with Israel at the top. And yet they
were bitterly disappointed.
So were they lying when they actually
went into Jerusalem and they were
proclaiming that Jesus was a king and he
was going to take over the throne? No.
the the date was correct.
>> Yes.
>> But the event that they believed was
wrong.
>> That's right.
>> So if you if you blame Mill uh William
Miller of lying, you would have to blame
the disciples of lying as well.
>> Yeah.
>> And so basically um as you were saying,
William Miller did the best he could
with the light that he had.
>> Yeah.
>> God expects much where there is much.
Yes,
>> God expects less where there is less.
>> Yes, he gave all he had while he could.
Ellen White makes a statement that he
was old, he had preached so much, he was
tired. Uh Sam Sheffield Snow and these
other guys kind of pushed him along and
he finally gave consent to that date,
but it was never really a big part of
his ministry. Interestingly enough, when
Christ made that that entry into
Jerusalem, um Elanor tells us who was
leading the donkey. It was it was
Lazarus. Yeah. So Lazarus didn't know
precisely what was going on, but he knew
something was going to happen good. So
he just out of out of joy and the
presence of the Holy Spirit, he he led.
So I like both of your points and I
agree with them that God gives us light
and we preach the light that we have,
you know, um and then as God gives us
more light, we move into that extra
light.
>> Yeah. you know uh I just like want to
read a two or three verses here in uh
Luke chapter 24 and uh verse 25 you know
these two disciples or followers of
Jesus on the road to Emmas they said you
know we thought he was the one who was
going to redeem Israel well did Jesus
redeem Israel
>> of course he redeemed Israel but it
wasn't the kind of redemption that they
were expecting and so it says in verse
25 he said to them oh foolish ones and
slow of heart to believe in all that the
prophets have spoken Ought not the
Christ to have suffered these things and
to enter into his glory? And beginning
at Moses and all the prophets, he
expounded to them in all the scriptures
the things concerning himself. And then
they say, "How could we ever
misunderstand what the event was going
to be?" And then later on, he meets the
disciples uh in the upper room at the
end of chapter uh 24 of Luke and it says
in verse 45, "And he opened their
understanding that they might comprehend
the scriptures."
Then he said to them, "Thus it is
written and thus it was necessary that
the Christ should suffer and to rise
from the dead on the third day." And it
says in the previous verse, verse 44,
that he spoke to them of Moses, the
prophets, and the Psalms, the things
concerning himself. They restudied
scripture and discovered they were wrong
about the event.
>> Yes.
>> The Millerites, the Seventh Day
Adventists, after the great
disappointment, they studied the
scriptures and they discovered the event
was wrong, but the date was right.
>> Yeah. We went through a number of things
we in trying to wrestle with what
happened. We we had to shut door which
we had to jettison. You know there were
a number of things we we tried out and
found out that they did not work. So it
wasn't lies. It's such that God was
giving more light and as we get more
light we walk in that light. Well
gentlemen thank you so very much for our
time together here at the general
conference session. We've had a good
time. And we hope that our presentations
have been informative, inspirational,
and spiritual. Our time has fast slipped
into eternity. Allow me now in closing
to with you both grace and peace through
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. We'll
see you again soon. Bye-bye and God
bless.
[Music]